[Music]
this is Star Talk Neil degrass Tyson
here your personal astrophysicist with
my co-host Chuck Nice Chuck yes Neil
what's happening we're doing another one
of these and this is going to be a
cosmic queries always a fan favorite and
this one is a topic that we should do
more often and what is that dark skies
and
astrophotography ooh
astrophotography this is how you get
into it oh my God everybody's got a
camera everybody's got you know I don't
know if the camera's that
good got this can I really do something
with my iPhone can I really I could give
you some advice but we got to go full
guns to get the all all the advice we
can here okay and we've got with us
right in the house babak
teshy babak babak teshy did I say that
right B back perfect perfect perfect hey
I see I did it right so there you are an
astrophotographer a space
photojournalist which sounds like you go
to space to get pictures but that's
probably not what it is but that's what
it sounds like Cosmo Paparazzi Man Cosmo
Paparazzi yeah let's get a closeup on
that Lander right uh soari over here
over here
alari
smile def who are you wearing who are
you
wearing your National Geographic
Explorer this is a highly uh privileged
coveted designation that goes to people
who are scattered around the world doing
their thing in the National Geographic
family of uh people bringing the
universe to the rest of us you're also
an amateur astronomer and we're going to
find out why that is a badge of honor
and not a denr ation uh you studied
physics in school love that and you're
an advocate for night skies dark skies
and that's another good thing and plus
you're a founder of the world at night
initiative we we'll get into that when
we uh get back to that and tell me what
you're about B back what what what
drives you what where what how did it
all begin and what's your relationship
with your mother let's get into this
very deeply very deep let's really get
into
it well I'm originally from Iran from
tan I'm Iranian American Science
journalist and photographer uh my
interest to astronomy started with the
first look at the Moon like many others
at the age of 13 I borrowed this
telescope on top of a roof in apartment
in Teran which is highly light polluted
uh had to look at the Moon and couldn't
believe my eyes you know it was much
more than the map I had in my hand all
the craters mountains and this was just
a tiny telescope 2 in you know all I can
remember that scene is still sicken by
second was almost like being the Appo
Orbiter going around the Moon because I
had no tracking with the telescope so it
was with the earth rotation the the
scene was moving across Across The View
and I thought you know that would be
cool to capture it on film so that was
the next night which wait just to be
clear you said something that I want
make sure our audience fully understands
you have a telescope that's not plugged
in it just points in One Direction and
the Moon is in the frame but because
Earth is
rotating the what's in the frame is
passing by and the magnification of the
telescope is such that you're basically
observing the rotation of the earth as
the sky goes by your your field anytime
you look through a telescope that
happens anytime you even take a picture
of the sky even you the phone if you go
beyond 30 seconds you start to see stars
are not pinpoint anymore or little
Trails this is a fact for the earth
rotation I mean it's a very easy
evidence of how Earth is rotating and
how the sky is turning above us that
sounds kind of annoying like it would
ruin every picture that's very true
that's very
true that's why we are limited with
shorter exposures less than 30 seconds
unless you use a device that tracks with
the Earth's rotation that can freeze the
earth rotation we call it the star treer
or use a motor motor attached to your
telescope that can track the Stars I
didn't have that that tiny telescope so
that why that's why the view was moving
and it felt like being in an orbit
around the moon so later on I became an
editor at astronomy magazine of Iran I
started the TV program for about 10
years we had a weekly TV program on a
space on astronomy I was highly inspired
by Neil in fact I emailed you back in
'90s if you can remember I'm not sure
but oh my gosh did I reply I you did you
did well that's good yeah this if you
didn't this would be very awkward right
now it would be an awkward moment
completely but I I do reply to all
emails eventually So eventually is
there so yes that was very inspiring to
me okay um yes I was very inspired by
Carl Sean at the time until you know
when he passed away I wrote one of my
first articles for astronomy magazine
about Carl Sean and later um I started a
program called the bo at night in 2007 I
was still based in Iran and since the
program became more and more Global with
exhibitions here and there I had to
leave Iran because it was not possible
with all the limitations from the
government and also the sanctions and
internet filation so me and my wife
decided to leave to Germany and later on
to the US I became a National Geographic
photographer in
2012 and recently much more involved
with naio across the platform with the
society and other parts of um the
platform of National Geographic so let's
go to questions now I think we we
covered the good ground here see what
and are very curious about this uh it's
good to see got to love this audience
this is
wrath who says hello Dr Tyson Lord nice
and Mr teshy uh by the way Chuck my last
name is pronounced wrath as in Wrath of
God or Wrath of Khan Tasha it's spelled
r a h I'm I think I'm capable of
pronouncing that thank you there's no
other way to pronounce that no other way
whatever like yeah exactly you know rata
yeah Tasha rata okay anyway she says I'm
from Oakland Califoria I hope my
question uh is what are the most
impactful actions individuals can take
to help protect the dark skies in their
home and
Community uh also are there any
stargazing apps that you can actually
recommend that are effective at
identifying objects in the night sky or
are they are are they all as dumb and
unhelpful as the ones I have
tried so I can answer the first one I'm
going to answer the first one boback you
don't have to mention this ready so
things you can do as an individual uh
walk around with a BB gun and shoot out
lights Bob actually agreed with that
I let me just say as the adult in the
room to all of our listeners we are not
condoning that you destroy public
Municipal property by shooting out
street lights okay which is something
drug dealers do so that they can do
their business true in the dark in the
dark so the individual what power does
the individual have well talking to your
communities if you're going to a church
to a temple to a mosque you know if
you're meeting with the family members
talk with the communities because this
is how the culture changes the problem
of light pollution is not like plastic
in the ocean which takes decades to
recover it's not like climate change we
are facing for the next Century to
recover that it's a very quick cultural
change night is is becoming brighter and
brighter by 2% every year on average
this is a very rapid change because of
our move to LEDs LEDs are much brighter
and if they're not used in a proper way
they can create much more sky glow
especially the white blue LEDs which are
harmful to human body as well by
changing our circadian rhythm so right
look at the light pollution not from the
perspective of astronomy it's very
important for astronom s but this is a
very small community in a larger scale
light pollution is waste of energy so
it's money involved light pollution
harms billions of birds and nocturnal
animals light pollution is about human
health as well by changing our sleep
cycle and then light pollution is
important to reduce to reconnect with
the night sky which is our origin and
probably our future so these are the
important elements to enter into the
discussion because I had the same
problem with my neighbors a few years
ago I was in a condo association and
there were very bright lights and it
took me three four weeks when I got to
that place to to just move the direction
to a way that it could be some changes
they they didn't feel safe without those
lights so first step was what kind of
light do we need here does it need to be
permanent or motion sensor in most cases
motion motion sensor lights are fine and
they're affordable widely available what
temperature of light do we need does it
need to be white blue or yellow in most
cases we see much better with yellow
light because you can see shadows and
illuminated areas at the same time with
white your eyes get saturated a quick
interjection uh Chuck and I have an
explainer on the temperature color of
light I think if I remember correctly
yes we do yeah just something that
people um normally don't think about a
temperature and what color light is but
of course in astrophysics it's
everything right it's the very found or
photography or photography except
there's some photographic language
that's the opposite all right when they
talk about a cooler light they refer to
Blue but blue is a higher color
temperature so there's some conflicting
language there but we straighten that
out in our little look look it up that's
a good explainer check it out yeah I
think color temperature and another
point before we pick you up by back is
um the LEDs are brighter wat for wat
which
means when you switch to LEDs you
actually save money even if the
illumination is brighter in the in the
zone so so you can save even more money
by chopping it down uh and so the switch
to LEDs was a money-saving move but you
don't want to be um irresponsible about
it which way is but the cool thing about
LEDs in addition to that is you can mix
the diodes so that you can create a
different color temperature yeah exactly
true that's what
they that explainer worked yeah
man why do you think I do this job man
I'm at school all the
time okay so B back pick it up I managed
to change the LEDs from 5,000 Kelvin
which is white blue it has you know 50%
blue light in it to 3,00 ,000 Kelvin
which we consider it a sky friendly for
interior at my home I use mainly 2200
Kelvin which is very appearing to the
eye it's very relaxed especially in
middle of the night if you want to go to
the bathroom if you have this bright
white light you have hard time going
back to sleep but with a soft yellow
light it's much easier to go because we
have some blue detectors in our retina
the cells are responsible only to detect
blue light it's almost near the center
of retina and those are triggering the
brain to drop melatonin and that of
course activates our body if you get too
much blue exposure that's why the blue
LEDs are not good for anybody um near
the bed time or anywhere near the
bathroom and and when you say drop
melatonin what you mean is restrict the
production of melatonin not literally
dropping melatonin yes yeah it cannot
yes it cannot right right right and back
your your voice is so soothing I have to
conclude that you get full night sleep
every time you you got your you yourself
to sleep in fact I just I just finished
the photo Workshop here for two weeks
where I didn't have any good night of
asleep oh okay okay by the way with what
you just said it's important for people
to know just as in the side uh not as in
the side as an addendum um when you're
reading screens at night if you're on a
tablet or your computer you should
change the blue light setting on your
screen because that could be disrupting
your sleep patterns as well as well yeah
that's true and you know this is the
same impact on many other species uh
with the white blue LED so LEDs are
essential change for energy saving there
is no doubt about that this is the
future that is already started but it's
the question of what kind of LEDs we
need to use at every place in the
offices we need white LEDs in Dental
rooms in surgery rooms you don't want
your surgeon to work on the red light
obviously but um do we need white LEDs
on a beach which is home to uh sea
turtles definitely not because they're
widely they're very largely impacted by
that light that's why many um turt
friendly beaches in FL Florida Costa
Rica Mexico they are changing the light
to
red and it's fully shielded we call it
full cut off you cannot see the bulb
from a distance it's only Illuminating
the ground where it's supposed to
illuminate is that so the turtles can
come to shore at night and lay their
eggs is what why two two reason one is
that because if the beach is too bright
they don't come there usually and the
second when the baby sea turt are
hatching they look for the brighter
Horizon which is naturally the ocean not
the buan the sand
but now this other Horizon with all the
hotels and the street lights it's much
brighter than the ocean they go to
opposite direction in land and of course
that that doesn't end very well that's
bad that ain't right that ain't right
see a turtle end up in a strip club
instead of the ocean that's terrible
that's terrible or the casino or the
casino it's terrible
Man Okay cool so how how long did it
take for you to affect that change it
took me 3 four weeks so it takes some
time and it's very important to start
with your local community because this
is how we're going to change this we are
naturally afraid of dark so on my
t-shirt it says addicted to the night
you know we we are going to become
acquainted with the nights to discover
that there is a beauty in this natural
Darkness it's good to have natural Dark
Nights some places it's impossible like
New York City but if there is a place
which is now dark enough for nocturnal
species and seeing the Milky Way let's
keep that keep it there way the way it
is all right Chuck give me another
question all right here we go uh this is
from our old friend Alejandro
Roso
okay from mon Mexico okay and he says
hello or should I say
hola okay my question is what is the
most difficult thing to
photograph and why oh I love that well
to me there has been many challenges of
course from the beginning when I started
in early 90s on film photography simply
the Milky Way was the most difficult
thing to capture properly because the
film was so low in sensitivity and then
you needed a star tracker device you
need a clear dark area which was not a
available to me in the city so that was
challenging today with your iPhone or
any smartphone you can capture the Milky
Way on first night on your first shot of
the night's Sky outside how much more
sensitive are the chips in phones
compared with a film you used back in
the early 90s right they use the same
terminology which is ISO so what would
be the equivalent so the fil is ISO 100
um at the time we were using 100 to 400
and above that it became very grainy um
very difficult to print large but
nowadays even the phone cameras are
using ISO of, 1600 3200 even higher with
some of the cameras I use for animals at
night we are shooting at ISO 50,000 to
100,000 and it's speaking almost every
single Photon that it arrives the
quantum efficiency the percentage of
photons which it can record it's up to
70 to
80% and um so at single digits the film
that's true sensitivity is single digits
yeah wow so there are handheld photos
you can take today that previously
required tripods even of the Milky Way
handheld photos with phone because the
phone is the stacking images it takes
quick shots of let's say half a second
and a stack the those which are not
shaky and give you a final image after 3
to 10 seconds even handheld you can see
the Milky Way uh but the challenge today
is more for me is more into objects such
as a supernova in the Milky Way which
didn't happen for the past 400 years or
a new Comet a bright new Comet or
atmospheric phenomena we are overdue for
a supernova in our in the movie exactly
okay expect one of these every every
every hundred years years or so and
we've gone 400 since Kepler's Supernova
in 1600s that we we we're overdue so
watch the night sky okay you guys are
worse than The Heirs of a rich a-hole
like don't worry one day that star is
gonna die real soon yeah in fact there
is one that can explode any
night any day now that star can die and
give us what we need baby don't you
worry okay so you saying it's hard to
photograph something that is transitory
right that you don't know when or where
it's going to happen that that would be
the top of the list and some of them are
atmospheric phenomena one of the objects
that I really love to capture um other
than mysterious things like red Sprites
they're related to Lightnings or blue
jets there is one object I have not
managed to document in fact it's never
been documented properly it's called
ball lightening
ball lightning yes why hasn't it ever
been photographed nobody knows some
scientists don't believe it exists and
some have many papers about it we should
say what it is first because some maybe
somebody not everybody knows what ball
lightning is it ain't Michael Jordan on
a good night or Steph Curry dropping
threes from outside to you know but what
is ball lightning it's a ball of charged
particles in the air that travels very
slowly sometimes fast and it's in the
size anywhere from a
basketball to maybe smaller and it has
been documented in the history visually
people have seen it this charged uh air
can even go through the walls or Windows
and so their paintings for example
people looking at this magical ball
coming in and they're um sometimes
explode of course because all the sudden
the charge particles are released uh
could be indoor and it can create damage
to it's usually happen in a very humid
condition uh so humid places are better
to observe them and we have many visual
documentation of that but never been
documented properly um by a camera that
you can rely on the image gotcha there
has been a couple of them and later on
we found out it was AI
generated okay so just to be clear the
reason why you have static electricity
um because charges build up
and you get near something where it can
discharge that will happen under dry
conditions because in dry conditions
that you will hold your charge until you
get near the object under damp
conditions you're constantly can
discharge but if you have a damp uh
environment then maybe the ball
lightning is itself in its own dry
pocket is that could that be what's
going on here I'm just trying that's
true yeah that's
put some Physics when I read one of the
explanation was that and you know there
are similar atmospheric phenomena that
has been never documented even red
Sprites were never documented until
1980s no nobody believed they exist some
of the UFO sighing that sighting we have
are in fact atmospheric phenomena which
are not fam familiar with right so the
recent hearings with NASA are
encouraging people with their
smartphones to capture anything they
don't understand and your smartphone has
metadata of location and time and the
like and bring it to a clearing house so
it might be some of these phenomena that
were so hard to catch before because
people weren't walking around with
cameras until very recently in the
history of civilization uh we could get
to the bottom of a lot of these
mysterious phenomena yeah it's like
people getting beat by the
cops it's just like that CH it's just
like yeah
you know before it was very unlikely you
would see that now we got cameras
everywhere it's just like wow why does
this happen every other day yeah no it's
always been happening right right right
thanks for that analogy Chuck that was a
Perfect Analogy yeah another question
I'm just I I'm just trying to get hate
mail okay no it's you can't get hate
mail for the truth this is Kevin the S
our friend Kevin the S who says uh for
someone who wants to get into
astrophotography
what would you recommend to get started
just like in return for someone who
wants to start their wine Journey they
would understand more like German
resling or New World Port Noir those are
great places to start well thanks for
the tip Kevin and and Neil what's a new
world uh Noir Pino Noir okay new world
is anything other than Europe that
planted Vines later than Europe so they
would be South America North America
like or Oregon or Washington State
exactly exactly and especially making
Wines in the European style and we might
even include Australia uh in a in a kind
of a new world sense of that right so
that's what he means by new world yeah
okay so how would you begin well you can
start with any digital camera with even
a cell phone but it needs to be on a
tripod so if you're using a cell phone
it needs to be on a an adapter that
connects to steady tripods then for
example on iPhone it can go up to 30
seconds it's good to activate the raw
format when you're taking an image on
the phone you have the possibility to
capture it on raw and if you're also
shooting with a proper camera you have
to shoot in raw because we need every
bit of information for low light images
night and Sky Images if you compress it
to jpeg it doesn't work very well and if
you're using a camera the most important
other than the camera itself which is
better to be a low light uh photography
device is the lens the lens needs to be
very fast meaning that the aperture of
the lens can open very wide wide so you
can get enough light in the short amount
of exposure that the earth rotation
dictates us because if you go with much
longer 10 minutes you get a beautiful
image of the star Trails not the
pinpoint
Stars so in order to receive enough
enough light in 30 uh seconds you need
to lose use a lens which has an aperture
of f2.8 or better such as F2 1.4 these
are fast lenses and then comes the place
because you need the darkest Sky
location so look at the darkest sky. org
website look at the light pollution map.
info website and these are sources you
can find dark sky places near you um
where is you you have to go to see the
Milky Way but also back to to the
question it's very important important
to know about the night of Sky if you're
going to be wildlife photographer you
have to know about the animals the same
is here it's it's fun and interesting to
learn about the stargazing so then you
realize what season is best for the
Milky Way what season can I capture
Beetle Juice and Orion what season is
best for the summer triangle or
brightest star Bea when can I get a
comment when is the best time for a
meteor shower and all these is a
knowledge that you can get gradually by
reading about practical astronomy it's
fun and it enables you to capture much
better images but B back what how do how
do how do you how do you make your your
smartphone take a 30- second image how
do you make it do that let me explain on
iPhone for example when you hold iPhone
it's limited the night mode on iPhone is
limited to 1 to 3 seconds handheld if
you keep it a steady it goes to 10
seconds usually you have to tap on the
night mode on the bottom and then
there's a slider you will see a slider
as soon as it's on a fixed tripod not
necessarily on a tripod but any fixed
platform even on a table on on theground
connect attached to a rock then you see
the slider goes to 30 seconds iPhone
will recognize vibration of your hand
look at that it automatically sees that
it's not vibrating and then extends the
time you're able to take the picture yes
on Google pixel it goes to four minutes
wow Google pixel goes to four
minutes so when you say raw you mean
uncompressed so you'd have to do that in
the settings for the camera where it
asks you what format yes under the
format when iPhone going to setting
camera for camera and then formats you
activate Apple Pro raw of course your
your uh phone needs to be the pro
version in order to have the raw and how
do you keep the image from getting too
bright because the longer you're exposed
the brighter the image will become if
you're in a fix position yeah especially
if you have Moonlight for example then
you don't need 30 seconds or if you're
near a city these 30 seconds High ISO
images will come into a result of
completely Overexposed image so it
depends on the moon condition um I
usually prefer to shoot the night of sky
during the present moon to first quarter
or last quarter when the moon phas is
between between 50% to
10% when your moon is brighter the
landscape will be beautifully
illuminated but the N sky is washed out
gotcha Chuck when I was younger I would
because the the Moon is just reflected
sunlight so you could take a picture at
night with the full moon or of of just
the landscape and if the exposure is
long enough and then you get the result
back it's like a daytime photo like you
would not know the difference exactly
it's just sunlight reflect it off the
with enough
exposure you get it yeah it's very
confusing when you look at yeah yeah yes
another little fact that the full moon
is about six times as bright as a half
moon and the the laws of reflection are
not uh
linear with the angle of sunlight
hitting the Moon versus the reflected
light to your eye so the full moon is
much much brighter and it's a it's a
mess for everything else in the sky for
sure so Chuck we got just a couple
minutes left what you got all right well
let's go to Jaden Peters Jaden Peters
says greetings from Ogden Utah amateur
astrophotographer here with a very easy
easy to pronounced name thank you Jaden
Jesus
Christ I was wondering what your
favorite celestial object to photograph
is and what equipment you have used to
photograph it I am truly inspired by
your beautiful beautiful
photos yeah I assume he's talking to me
yes yeah that's definitely your fan he
he let me tell you something he's not
talking about my
Instagram
well definitely the Northern Lights is
one of my favorite because it's ever
changing especially when Aurora is
overhead is creating u a kind of a known
as crown and it's almost like raining in
colors down to you it's a effective
perspective in fact and that is my most
U favorite object in the night sky to
shoot unfortunately not possible to
shoot it from my neighborhood in Boston
area due to light pollution and latitude
but from Iceland from anywhere noric
countries Alaska Northern Canada these
are frequently viewed another object
that I love to photograph is a bright
comet and those are not very common
every decade we have one great Comet the
last one in the northern hemisphere was
two decades ago in
1997 uh Comet hellbo and then we had
2007 another great comet in the southern
hemisphere of sky and nothing after that
there were good comets but nothing we
can call a great Comet so I'm really
looking forward to it something like
headbob can be be viewed from middle of
New York City so it's very impressive to
look at it in the darkest Sky it has
maybe tail of 30 40 degrees I remember
comeet haake in 95 the tail in darkest
sky was 90
degrees wow okay so but you can't summon
up a comet nor can you summon up the
Northern Lights uh so you have to be
very opportunistic when these events are
available to you correct how about for
us mere mortals is there any pedestrian
that you really like the Milky Way the
Milky Way is like elephants in Wildlife
Safari so that's what you're going to
see and you know it's unfortunate that
more than
95% of population in developed world can
no longer see the Milky Way from their
living area because of light pollution
and that includes North America and
Europe if you include the entire world
it's about 60% now that's they cannot
see the Milky Way anymore so there are
Generations who have never seen the
Milky Way I had a recent program um and
a New York Times um retired journalist
was with us and she never saw the Milky
Way in 80 years living in New York City
for the first time she saw it in this
program I do every August in Maine and
she was almost crying she was so
impressed by the beauty of course she
was also disappointed that the Milky Way
didn't appear to the eyes with color
because our eyes cannot pick the real
color of any diffused object at
nighttime we're not sensitive enough to
Colors
oh interest spoiled by
Hubble or the James
WB so Chuck bring it on F quickly go
it's a super fast super fast this is
Jason and he says have either of you
that means the two of you not me have
either of you ever seen something that
gave you an undeniable truth about
something else so you look through your
lens and you see something that confirms
something that a truth in another area
of your life I think that's a great
question well since 90 early 90s it's
been like 30 years since my teenager
that I've been photographing the night
sky I captured many
UFOs but every time an astronomer
explained that so for me uh there has
been some uh really exciting moments
first time I captured a rocket exhaust
for example or this Cloud coming out
from the extra fuel dumped by a rocket
in the upper atmosphere or the first
time I captured a military grain drone I
had no idea I thought this is a UFO or
first time I captured an exploding
Fireball a very bright meteor we call it
bite and these were really changing
moments in my career and uh then I
learned something that these are natural
phenomenal or man-made phom phons and I
still have a few objects in my images
which are not explained and I imagine
they're related to uh large drones oh
look at that so your UFOs became ifos in
the presence of expertise all that
happened there I would say for me a a a
moment that I won't soon forget it was
1999 where we expected a meteor storm
because Earth was passing very close
to the what was the head of the Comet
responsible for the debris that we're
plowing through as we orbit the Sun so
rather than a few good meteors every
five minutes you'd expect maybe a few
good meteors per minute or even a higher
rate than that so I'm there midspan of
the Brooklyn Bridge in New York City and
I'm looking up and I see a
star just appear out of nowhere
and it just got brighter and brighter
and
brighter and it then it
disappeared and I said whoa then I had
to like I'm thinking in like fast time
here and I say well that's not a meteor
meteor streak left and right and up and
down and I said oh my God must be an
angel I oh no I said yes it was a
meteor headed straight for me
yes oh my God that's what I'm saying
snap I had to deduce this from first
principles I say if they're hit me at
all angles at some point what's a meteor
G to look like when it's headed straight
towards you wow oh my gosh yeah
fortunately most meteors from a shower
are coming from Icy objects
so so it got brighter and brighter and
then of course it dissipated into the
atmosphere and then that was it
that was it and and and I said damn now
I know what my last moments on Earth
will look like if a meteor is gonna take
me
out yo that is oh man I never heard that
story before that's super oh no you
never told me that you look at me
Showers you see them time to time I have
pictures of them they're just like
Supernova because they just show up and
then they disappear yeah yeah yeah wow
so how do we get people before we uh
continue to get out and to look up I
mean Neil's always saying keep looking
up how about the people who aren't
looking up at all to they not keep
looking up how do they start looking up
I think a trip to a national park or
State Park in a darkest sky place um is
the best way to do this because many of
the national parks in the US and Canada
are darkest Sky designated locations
especially in Southwest us some of my
favorites for example in Arizona Nevada
the border is the Western end of Grand
Canyon um or the Great Basin National
Park it's at high altitude in the B and
it's also very dark uh there are plenty
of darkest Sky locations that area all
the five major national parks in Utah
are darkest Sky designated or going to
be soon in North Western Nevada we have
the Black Rock Desert another darkest
sky place even very close to Las Vegas
on the way to Bey on the way to Death
Valley there's a darkest Sky area
another place I have photographed many
times it's Cathedral Gorge which is
inside Nevada on the border of Utah and
it's just fascinating um rock formations
with the darkest sky above it awesome or
all of Australia and
Central yeah no but you're right if most
of the population of the world lives in
the Northern Hemisphere and most of that
population lives near cities then we
have to be very surgical about how we
get the these people out there they need
to know where to go is there a map they
can go to online that identifies these
dark spots there are two ways to do that
one is um light pollution
mapinfo uh that's a website and there is
also a layer for Google Earth um a
University study provided this layer of
um known as the um the map the atlas of
artificial icial Sky glow um and this
you can add it to your Google Earth and
then you can zoom in and see another
place another website is blue-m marble.
De it's German Enthusiast who includes
all these satellite images from every
year you can look at Earth at night and
find darkest Sky places near you but do
not forget that elevation is not there
so if you even if you're in a bright
area but you find an elevated side which
is at least 4,000 5,000 ft above sea
level
then you start to see darkest Sky even
within the cities
gotcha interesting very cool and right
now you are speaking to us from Iceland
what are you doing there today from
rovic Iceland this was my last day after
two weeks of a photo Workshop capturing
the northern lives and the Milky Way
with a group coming from all around the
country I do this um all around the
world I do this twice a year in March
and September known as Aurora Photo
Tours oh wow so people people can
actually hang out with you and learn how
to do what you're doing is oh look at
that yeah I do four five workshops my
invitation might still be in my inbox
I'm guessing exactly
yes any time nail check let me check my
inbox if I've ever been invited on this
so you made a career of this this is I
this is a a brilliant important and
envious career path that you've made for
yourself here congratulations on that
thank you keep that going all right uh
Chuck we out all right this was fun all
right and B back thanks again for being
our guest on Star Talk all right I'm
Neil degrass Tyson your personal
astrophysicist finishing up this Cosmic
queries edition of our search for night
skies in the world as always especially
after this episode keep looking
up
[Music]